okay so uh i wrote this piece and i said
arsenal's gonna be a billion dollar
brand
if basically you don't sell too early
right and the whole idea was just you
have
the fan base and it was so obvious early
on like if you have the relationship
with the fans
you win because you can create companies
sell it through products sell it through
whatever
at some point you decide one to sell
right ip's not nothing but a piece
and then two you do it where now you're
focusing all your energy on somebody
else's product it's not something that
you guys created talk through like why
do that versus just go start your own
sports book plus a bunch of other stuff
and put it through the
distribution you mean here with like pen
with pen well we could never start our
own sports book we'd never get licensed
we'd never get access
we all that [ __ ] would just never happen
so um
you needed the partner to needed the
partner and they were the perfect
partner and again
it is a question i get asked a lot but
when you're in our shoes and i've been
[ __ ] grinding at this thing for 17
years
um you know i made money but
and it's all relevant like i i'm
obviously have done well
but when you look at the churning deal
it's not like i was obscenely rich like
i had money but that wasn't like oh my
god
and even now it's not like now where you
can tweet that celebrity net worth that
hey
correct 200 million right um on paper
uh but so this what and there are
it's not as if we have this waterfall
of offers and meetings when you're going
through and
you're nobody's making an offer it's
like well is anyone get an offer and as
do i want to do this for the next 20
years to build it up
i always thought sports gambling is how
we started the second
the legislation the united states
changed to make it legal
i'm like okay this is our moment and we
spent close to a year
trying to figure out the best fit and
penn was
by far and away the best partner that
presented itself from jay snowden who i
love the ceo
to them understanding what we do and
having faith and believing in it
um there was it it was almost a
no-brainer i mean we named our price
there was no negotiation with penn and i
thought it was crazy because based on
how did you call it the price i didn't
like the you know the char and
the churning guys as you said are fierce
negotiators
so if they're naming it i'm like okay
but they named it and and penn was like
yup
that's it done they didn't negotiate it
was nothing as long as they felt
we were aligned and we are because it's
not like i got paid it's like
a lot of stock and all that [ __ ] how
much did you take in stock versus cash
it was like it it was uh 5545.
55k uh cash casher stock 55 stock 45
and that's like different for me it's
like the barcelo people are different
than the chernobyl yeah yeah so
i mean it was a great deal now when the
stock goes up and bumps pre-corona
you know it's like oh we should dump we
just made them a gazillion dollars in 10
seconds
because wall street reacted obviously
super favorably to the deal
and that's when the other companies we
met with who i like like
obviously it's like the brady six when
he's crying like i get a chip on my
shoulder
like i'm meeting with these guys who
know us it's like you're not gonna make
an offer you're [ __ ] an
idiot and they've probably had to spend
on talent now more than they would have
spent just to buy us
because we put them in a box it's like
oh [ __ ] well what is it fanduel did the
pat mcafee deal right
yep on top they're doing well all of
them
yes because like okay and they could
have
they missed and i don't know if they'd
say they missed you but they miss
because i actually really like the
fanduel guys and the ones running it
it's like if they made an offer that was
competitive it's like okay we can win
with these guys i feel like everyone in
the
gambling sports fantasy world are people
like barstow
right like the type of person is so
similar so the people who are running
those companies
there's a very cultural fit with what
you guys have done ooh
maybe not not at the top okay that's
different
yeah maybe down below but that's why
we're gonna be like i i've met with them
all
they don't they're they're not like how
bad does this get in the sense of fast
forward five years
the barstool sports book versus all
these other guys
like how bad of a massacre is it oh i
don't know because they have such a
gigantic
lead they have great tech they have a
huge lead um
and there's no industry that i'm aware
of where there's like
one guy i mean it doesn't matter what
there is there's multiple players and
they're competitive and
in a way it can help each other but
nobody outside like i guess the cable
company and telephone well even there's
model but
you can only get one cable company in
your house other than that
there'll be multiple players like
fanduel and draftkings are not going
anywhere yeah
we're we're different like those two
to me are
one of those i don't know what'll happen
though they're identical companies to me
they're both out of the daily fantasy
the big databases
they're gonna try to win with offers and
plays no one cares no one's gonna wear
fanduel hat or draft as much as they try
that's never gonna happen
but they're they're gonna be there we
and i saw one interesting stat when i
was looking at downloads and it's like
it didn't our downloads and what we did
in pennsylvania
and handle all that didn't seem to take
away from the others and i could believe
that
oh interesting so it was additive to the
correct because we have our audience who
makes sense have been so you know it
could help
both markets i could and who knows i'm
anybody who thinks i've inside we talked
insider knowledge like you came in
and i'm like well pen was down 10 they
did this stock offering
i had no idea that was coming and i have
so much pen stock
even beyond like you know why they don't
tell you right
because it's our trading no no because
telling you wouldn't be bad because
you're an employee
but then then you'd go then you would go
sell it and you get yourself into
correct exactly so
so they basically know you better than
you know yourself they protect me but
it's still
so they told me just late last night so
i wouldn't
be like stunned by the news well i'm so
confident in myself and what we do here
that i just keep buying it as it goes
like i'll bet on myself 100 so when he
told me that
i would never know this if i wasn't
doing the day trader like oh
stocks can't get killed like not because
pen anytime
a company does this stock is killed i've
seen it like i've owned stocks i'm like
what the [ __ ] is it down and people like
oh they did an offering
it doesn't generally last it comes back
but when he told me that
it's like i'm sitting here with i'm like
all right you [ __ ] like
i'm gonna get murdered tomorrow and it's
like i have to wake up all these people
and sure enough it did they buried some
good stats but
yeah it's uh hold on before we talk
about the stock stuff you guys launched
the sports book
in pennsylvania this past weekend you
outperformed
downloads for all the other ones did you
guys have to spend money to drive that
or is that all organic just putting it
through the distribution
which to me which is the big advantage
that you guys have yeah so
that is the story and that's why
even the way they did this release if
they can't tell me like the press
release and all that
i feel like they should talk because i'm
understand marketing i feel like better
than they do
like it's stock offering and then at the
bottom it like had the stats
and the stats and people twist them
people don't like me will say they're
bad they're good
it's like i think i have it's like
thirty thousand
it's like thirty thousand downloads
downloads in pennsylvania 11 million
handle like 24 000 registrations
is really really impressive there's 10
existing companies
sports books in pennsylvania with a huge
lead on us
we know where it's like a race that is a
a 10 mile race
and the other companies are are five
miles in and we're just starting
there's no other company in the world
who could have that dent with zero
dollars spent we didn't spend a cent
so how and when you guys go to market
this how much
is this just you send a message to
everyone here and you're like hey we're
launching this like
you know go promote it versus it's uh
specifically like okay we're gonna
promote it on this show we're gonna
promote on this show like how should i
teach you guys it's pretty just promote
it however
like you see fit that's what it looks
like which makes it so much more
valuable yep
and that that is how it is and it's a
natural because our history is gambling
and then i was saying like extrapolate
it you know take a state like michigan
where it is not legal yet
and that's like i went to school there
we're huge in the midwest
penn has one of the nicest casinos there
that the greek which is
like i think their nicest las vegas
style casino
and all of a sudden everyone's at the
starting line at the same time
well we're gonna cause real damage there
so not everyone's totally understanding
that i guess some people do some people
don't
but pennsylvania was as encouraging i
think as
we could possibly expect it to be and
like the stock offering thing
again like we're not unless i'm being
strictly lied to which i know i'm not
that's money is not going to people's
hands or using it as
it was i said to give me like guns
ammunition so we can start spending
so